[Musique]
donc atteint
c'est un aliment du quotidien dans nulle
n'imaginerait se passer dans les rues de
yaoundé
le pain une denrée de plus en plus rares
et de plus en plus cher depuis
l'explosion des cours du blé mais ici
dont les fours de ces boulangeries de
nouvelles farine pourrait bientôt
remplacer le blé
pour faire son pain hervé nyama a décidé
de miser sur un nouvel ingrédient
le manioc bélanger ici à une farine de
patates douces des tubercules
d'ordinaire consommer non transformé
dans les plats traditionnels camerounais
et de manor semman et plus facilement
comme la farine de blé on peut le manger
sans avoir de problèmes par contre nous
avons une qualité des personnes d'ici
dix ans qui ne peut pas manger le public
pourquoi andy parce que le bel inconnu
sub ssa qu'on appelle le gluten le
manioc made in cameroon utilisé comme
alternative au blé importé jusqu'à lors
hervé et sa hiérachie n'y avait même pas
pensé mais la hausse du prix du sac de
farine de blé a tout changé il est passé
en quelques jours d'un peu moins de 30
euros environ 40 euros les 50 kg une
hausse provoquée par la baisse des
importations depuis le début de la
guerre en ukraine d'où l'apparition de
ces nouveaux peu à la patate et au
manioc
nous sommes en phase d'expérimentation a
dit que pouvoir comment est-ce que ça va
se comporter mail ou de tous que nous
avons dit nous avons jusqu'ici je peux
deal est très positif la cuisse
ukrainienne est un élément qui nous a
boostés et en vue dont la flambée de
l'appareil du glay ça nous a boostés à
accélérer
la production et l'utilisation de la
parade nautique comment locales 12 euros
le pain de patates douces un euro celui
au manioc des prix bien supérieurs au
traditionnel pain de blé
mais la clientèle est au rendez-vous
séduite par l'idée du consommer des
ingrédients locaux est enfin à base de
farine bio se trouve que c'est
intéressant c'est bien parce qu'enfin on
va consommer du local nous devons
commencer à consommer les produits de ce
lot
le manioc pourrait-il à terme
définitivement remplacé le blé certains
producteurs un rêve si tubercules facile
à faire pousser sur des sols pauvres
résiste aux chaleurs tropicales mais il
est vulnérable à certaines maladies
comme la mosaïque du manioc ou la
striure brune
qui peuvent décimer toute une récolte
pour vingt-deux mille hectares de terres
cultivées le cameroun produit environ 5
millions de tonnes de manioc chaque
année dont d'énormes plantations comme
celle ci à une centaine de kilomètres de
la capitale comme on trompe
les côtés depuis 2014 rosalie ma cultive
le tubercule dans ses 140 hectares de
plantations une production abondante à
chaque récolte malgré le manque que deux
machines agricoles sophistiquée elle
voit la flambée des cours du blé comme
une aubaine pour les milliers de
cultivateurs comme elle est allée
variétés qui donne 30 tonnes à l'hectare
et le typhon 500 tonnes à l'hectare les
producteurs de the manner peuvent
répondre à tout type demande que ce soit
à l'intérieur du pays que ce soit dans
la zone ces marques ce soit en afrique
et et voir à l'occident à condition que
le gouvernement nous apporte un appui
dans la mécanisation avec l'arrivée de
la guerre de la guerre de l'ukraine ou
la farine de blé a grimpé tout d'un coup
chaque jour mon téléphone n'arrête pas
de sonner
madame escaut pour mes livres et 10
tonnes de farine de manioc est ce que
vous me livrer 20 ans de matane de manor
pouvoir faire booster l'économie
convaincu si van the man who
la culture du manioc est déjà en plein
boom dans de nombreux pays en afrique
avant la crise ukrainienne life à eau a
bien alerté sur des risques
d'appauvrissement des sols liée à sa
monoculture intensive
mais ses mises en garde n'ont pas freiné
l'ardeur des producteurs locaux dans
cette coopérative qui transforme des
dizaines de tonnes de manioc en farine
le rythme s'est accéléré
le procédé de fabrication reste encore
presque entièrement manuelle et les
producteurs de manioc appellent de leurs
voeux une mécanisation qui leur ferait
changer d'échelle de production pas moi
canton de la zone pas avoir
son insu la de machines le cameroun aura
pas de farine de manioc ça va remplacer
le blé facilement parce que beaucoup de
gens vont comprendre et tout le monde va
s'allier à la fin du manioc
le manioc un ingrédient que cet autre
coopérative entend rendre incontournable
la production d'un à stasi obama
s'arrachent déjà au cameroun comme à
l'étranger
qu'on fait l'otan ont fait des gâteaux
ont fait les beignets
ont fait les biscuits ont fait même les
liqueurs mois montmagny hawks ont mangé
dans le monde entier la lomagne la
farine que vous voit elle l'est moins
que vaut elle ça parle même aux états
unis
avec l'augmentation de la demande
mondiale les pays africain producteur de
manioc qui compte déjà parmi leurs
clients des grandes multinationales de
l'alimentation
peuvent espérer conquérir encore du
nouveau marché